written in the sky over tel aviv the
story of just how quickly and decisively
this conflict has escalated
central israeli suburbs taking direct
hits
from an enormous barrage of rockets
fired out of gaza
concentrated into a few short minutes a
proportion
piercing the iron dome interceptor
defenses
as military hardware was transported
closer to the gaza border
israel's prime minister defense minister
and internal security service chief
addressed an attack on central israel
the like of which had not been seen
in three gaza wars since 2008.
hamas and the islamic jihad will pay a
heavy price for their aggressiveness
the blood is on their hands
hamas had warned of a major strike on
tel aviv if
israel targeted residential buildings in
gaza
a little after sunset after telling the
families who lived here to get out
israel's military did just that
the israeli prime minister had warned of
a gathering intensity and pace of attack
the army said the building was in part
used by hamas
the promised retaliation came swiftly in
a coordinated
mass launch towards tel aviv
this is a wave after wave of attacks
coming out of gaza now these rockets
are heading in the direction of tel aviv
we understand there are already sirens
being sounded
in tel aviv and explosions heard hamas
had warned
that it would launch such an attack if
israel destroyed
residential buildings inside gaza the
destruction of that large building
appears to have led to this big
escalation in what already was a
dangerous situation
it was the second time in a day that
such a barrage had been fired
this was the effect of the earlier one
in the town of ashkelon where two women
were killed
in gaza two eruptions of overpowering
sudden grief
this was the funeral of an
eleven-year-old boy who was killed on
monday
one child among many dead already in the
first hours of this conflict
as still another generation experiences
firsthand
the reality of israeli air strikes on
this crowded impoverished
besieged strip of land
if they want to escalate the resistance
is ready if they want to stop
the resistance is ready if they want to
move their hand out of jerusalem
the resistance is ready this is the
message that we deliver to all the sides
and to whoever is involved
and as the crisis deepened between
israel and gaza's fighting factions
a parallel crisis was breaking out
within israel's mixed jewish arab towns
after a palestinian israeli was shot
dead by a jewish man the previous night
an explosion of intercommunal violence
this a synagogue set ablaze
[Applause]
the government is sending in security
forces usually stationed in the occupied
west bank
declaring a state of emergency after
weeks of tension
and sparks of violence the fire has
caught
and it's spreading harry fawcett
al-jazeera southern israel